Hello, my name is Zisl Slepovitch
and I'm musician in residence at Yale
University's Fortunoff Video Archive
for Holocaust Testimonies.
This video series is designed as a
companion to our album, Where Is
Our Homeland, which is the first volume
in the Archive's ongoing effort to
present songs and poems
performed by survivors in testimonies
given to the Fortunoff Archive over
the last 40 years.
You can learn more about the project on
the Archive's website,
songsfromtestimonies.org.
Where Is Our Homeland?
Songs from Testimonies.
Volume One was recorded in 2019
by the Zisl Slepovitch Ensemble,
featuring renowned singer Sasha
Lurje, Craig Judelman on the violin,
Joshua Camp on the accordion, keyboards
and guitar, Dmitry Ishenko
on the bass, and myself on woodwinds.
The songs in this collection differ
vastly in terms of style, social
and historical background, language
and many other aspects.
But collectively they create a
multidimensional picture of Jewish
life before and during World War II.
In this episode, we will be
continuing talking about
and listening to the songs sung
by Liubov' K.,
a native of the Ukrainian town
of Zvenigorodka,
a former inmate of the slave labor
camp in the same area.
This musical project began
with Liubov's interview,
with Liubov's testimony
and this song, Proshchay-
Farewell is written in Russian.
It was remembered by Liubov' as a
poem that people
who were-- who were leaving
their homes, abandoning
their dear
places that they loved
all their lives, they were passing
this poem to each other
in this way, sharing that sorrow
and sustaining and supporting
each other.
I wrote music to this
poem in the genre of Salon
Romance, of the Bard song
so popular in the Soviet
Union, and
it came from the even earlier
era, from the 19th century
sentimentalism,
sentimentalists song that was
very popular in the former
Russian empire, an urban genre
that was also shared by people
and was used to convey
earnest feelings.
So Proshchay, Farewell.
Farewell, our native city.
Farewell, family so dear.
Farewell, precious mothers.
[wait…] (trying to remember)
Farewell, to all our friends.
Blindly, we walk down the road,
Not knowing what lies ahead.
The ominous thought is growing,
That awaiting us is death.
From the distant mountains,
Nemorozh’s houses peer out.
Heavily the heart begins to pound
And tears begin to fall.
What a home we were given,
A pig stall without a window or a door.
A heavy wind blew right through us,
And chilled us down to the bones.
At first we were not used to it,
Such savagery, brutality.
With sweat we toiled to till the earth
And watered it with tears.
Farewell, our native city.
Farewell, family so dear.
Farewell, precious mothers.
Farewell, to all our friends.
Blindly, we walk down the road,
Not knowing what lies ahead.
The ominous thought is growing,
That awaiting us is death.
From the distant mountains,
Nemorozh’s houses peer out.
Heavily the heart begins to pound
And tears begin to fall.
What a home we were given,
A pig stall without a window or a door.
A heavy wind blew right through us,
And chilled us down to the bones.
At first we were not used to it,
Such savagery, brutality.
With sweat we toiled to till the earth
And watered it with tears.
After launching Operation Barbarossa
on June 22, 1941,
the German army reached the central
Ukrainian town of Zvenigorodka
on July 29th.
In 1939, the Jewish population
of the city had hovered just below 2,000,
with Jews representing approximately
14% of the total population.
Liubov' K. recalls that the first
few days of the German occupation
were relatively calm.
However, the Germans soon began going
house to house to pillage and
to terrorize the local inhabitants.
In September of that year, the Germans
forced all Jews in
Zvenigorodka to move into a ghetto which
occupied only two streets and one
alley.
Conditions in the ghetto were so crowded
that there were two to three families
living in each house.
Although the Zvenigorodka ghetto was not
walled off, it was closely
guarded by Germans and local
auxiliary police known as the politsai.
In the ghetto, young, able-bodied
Jews like Liubov' were assigned
to menial and humiliating tasks
such as cleaning latrines.
As they worked, non-Jewish schoolchildren
taunted them by singing antisemitic
ditties and mocking their misfortunes.
On May 2, 1942,
the Jews of nearby Ol'shana were
brought to the Zvenigorodka ghetto.
Shortly thereafter, on May 5th,
the Ukrainian politsai and German
gendarmerie rounded up approximately
300 able-bodied Jews
from the ghetto and transferred them
to an improvised labor camp in
the village of Nemorozh, which lies
eight kilometers northwest of
Zvenigorodka.
In her interview, Liubov' recalls,
"A German came to us
and said we should take two changes of
clothing, underwear, outerwear
and go to the Jewish Council."
There they would await their transfer to
an uncertain future.
In late September, early October
of the previous year, a detachment
of Einsatzkommando 5 had rounded
up one hundred Jewish men from the
Zvenigorodka ghetto on the pretext
of taking them for labor somewhere else.
Instead, they were shot in Laptev
meadow.
This was the first mass shooting of
Zvenigorodka Jews.
So in May 1942, when
Liubov' and approximately three hundred
other Jews were rounded up to be taken
for labor, they were understandably
prepared for the worst.
It is this profound sense of anguishing
uncertainty that inspired the
words of their song Proshchay,
which Liubov' recites in her testimony.
"Farewell our native city.
Farewell, family so dear.
Farewell, precious mothers.
Farewell to all our friends.
Blindly, we walk down the road,
not knowing what lies ahead.
The ominous thought is growing that
awaiting us is death."
As it turned out, the Germans had
other plans for this group of three
hundred Zvenigorodka and Ol'shana Jews.
Liubov' and her fellow prisoners were
taken to Nemorozh, where they were forced
to perform backbreaking labor on
the transit highway number IV,
which stretched from L'viv in the west
to Taganrog in Russia
in the east, with tributary roads
running north to south.
Liubov' and the other Jewish prisoners in
the Nemorozh camp worked on one
such tributary road, which
led north to Kiev.
The laborers were given only the most
rudimentary of tools, shovels
and picks, with which they were asked
to build, maintain and repair
the highway.
And while the labor they provided was
valuable, the German overseers
and local auxiliary police who guarded
them saw these prisoners as expendable.
To say the conditions in the
Nemorozh camp were rustic would be a
profound understatement.
The prisoners lived in an unheated barn
and as Liubov' recalls,
"we slept directly on the ground.
There was nothing to cover ourselves
with. So we returned from work
in our clothes and ate the thin
gruel that they gave us.
They cooked it for us twice a day,
morning and evening, no salt,
a quarter of a bucket of millet
to 17 buckets of water."
The prisoner's daily struggle for
survival under these conditions inspired
the words of their song, "such
a home we were given, a pig stall
without a window or a door.
A heavy wind blew right through us.
And chilled us down to the bone.
At first we were not used to it,
such savagery, brutality.
With sweat, we toil to till the
Earth and watered it with tears."
In the evenings after work ended,
Liubov' and her fellow prisoners passed
the time by singing and composing songs.
This process of writing
songs and sharing them boosted
their morale immeasurably as they endured
daily hardships and losses,
giving voice to their feelings of hope
and despair.